From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life.
来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。
Step one, you are currently in the custody of the US department of Homeland Security Customs and Border Protection. You have been charged with the crime of illegal entry into the United States. Step two--
第一步，你目前正处于美国国土安全部海关及边境保卫局的拘留之下。你已被指控犯有非法入境美国的罪行。第二步——
So Kevin, who is this and what is she reading?
凯文，这是谁？她在读什么？
This is Rachelle Garza. She's an immigration attorney in Brownsville, Texas and she's reading a flyer that was handed to some parents after they were separated from their children.
这是雷切尔·加尔萨。她是德克萨斯州布朗斯维尔的一名移民律师，她正在阅读一份传单，这份传单是在一些父母与孩子被迫分离后发给他们的。
Kevin Sieff is correspondent for The Washington Post.
凯文·谢夫是《华盛顿邮报》的记者。
And on the flyer there's a phone number, basically, which is really the only lifeline they have to their children-- the only way they can get information from the government about where their children are, how their children are doing.
传单上有一个电话号码，基本上，这是他们与孩子取得联系的唯一生命线——这是他们从政府那里获知孩子下落及近况的唯一途径。
And explain what she's trying to do.
解释一下她想做什么。
She's trying to locate her client's child. So she represents a man who is detained in an immigration detention center who, basically minutes after crossing the border, was separated from his daughter.
她想找到她客户的孩子。她代理了一名被关押在移民拘留中心的男子，他在越境后仅仅几分钟就与女儿分开了。
How old is his daughter?
他女儿多大？
She's 12
她12岁。
OK, so let's figure out how we're supposed to do this. So action one, call ICE. If you're in a detention facility, call this way. OK, let's call the ORR parent hotline.
好吧，那我们来看看该怎么做。第一步，致电美国移民及海关执法局（ICE）。如果你在拘留设施内，请这样拨打。好的，我们来拨打难民安置办公室（ORR）的家长热线。
What is that, the ORR parent hotline?
那是什么，ORR家长热线？
So, that's the phone number that you're supposed to call, either as a parent or as an attorney, to try to locate your child. I mean, it's really the most-- when you look at this flyer, it's the most useful piece of information on it. So yeah, this is the number that Rochelle's about to call.
那是你作为家长或律师应该拨打的电话号码，目的是尝试找到你的孩子。我的意思是，当你看着这张传单时，这是上面最有用的信息。没错，这就是雷切尔马上要拨打的号码。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
So it starts in Spanish, and then it switches to English.
所以它先用西班牙语，然后切换到英语。
You have reached the ORR national call center, open 24 hours a day, seven days a week. If you are calling about a person travelling to the United States who is 18 years of age or older, please press one. If you have a case manager's extension, please press two. For all other calls, please press three or remain on the line and you will be connected with a case manager. Your call will be monitored for quality assurance.
你已接通ORR全国呼叫中心，我们全天24小时，每周七天为您服务。如果你拨打此电话是为了查询一位年满18周岁或以上的前往美国的人员，请按1。如果你有案件经理的分机号，请按2。如需其他咨询，请按3或保持在线，我们将为你连接一位案件经理。你的通话将被录音以保证服务质量。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
OK, so there's hold music and there's a phone tree. This all feels very, like-- the most normal thing in the world.
好的，有等待音乐和自动语音菜单。这感觉非常……非常正常。
Exactly. It's like you're trying to fix your cable.
没错。就像你在尝试修复有线电视一样。
So on this recording you made, an operator picks up after six minutes-- not that long, really.
在你录制的这段录音中，接线员在六分钟后接听了——其实并没有那么久。
Please wait as we connect--
请稍候，我们正在为你转接——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]?
[西班牙语对话]？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
Yes, of course.
是的，当然。
OK, how are you doing Alan?
好的，艾伦，你好吗？
Pretty good.
挺好的。
So, my name is Rochelle Garza. I'm an attorney.
我叫雷切尔·加尔萨。我是一名律师。
OK.
好的。
I'm looking for my client's daughter. I called last week, on the 11th of June, and I was told that I would be contacted by the shelter.
我在找我客户的女儿。我上周，也就是6月11日打过电话，当时我被告知避难所会联系我。
The shelter?
避难所？
Yeah. And I haven't been contacted, and neither has my client.
是的。但我没有收到联系，我的客户也没有。
OK. What's the name of the minor?
好的。未成年人的名字是什么？
So she gives the name of this girl to the operator and he looks her up and finds her in the system.
她把女孩的名字告诉了接线员，他查找了系统并找到了她。
What I can do is to try to do-- try to send the shelter inquiry again. I mean, because they usually do contact. But right now, with the high volume of minors that are entering the United States, it's a little complicated for them.
我能做的是尝试——尝试再次向避难所发送查询。因为他们通常会联系。但目前，随着进入美国的未成年人数量激增，对他们来说有点复杂。
Hey Kevin, when he says the high volume of minors entering the United States, is that what's happening?
嘿凯文，当他说进入美国的未成年人数量激增时，事实确实如此吗？
No. I mean, there is no surge of minors crossing the border. In fact, there are fewer people crossing the border than almost any time in the last decade. What there's a surge of is a surge of families being separated, and that's what's changed.
不。并没有出现未成年人越境的激增。事实上，越境人数比过去十年中的任何时候都要少。真正激增的是被迫分离的家庭数量，这就是变化之处。
And that's why he's getting so many calls.
这就是为什么他会接到这么多电话的原因。
Right. There are children and parents who can't find each other.
对。有太多孩子和父母找不到彼此。
Maybe there's a better way for us to do this. Can I send a letter to you or to the shelter somehow, saying that I'm representing her father? That way I can at least confirm, you know, where she is and so I can go ahead and start working on her case.
也许我们可以换种方式。我可以寄一封信给你或避难所吗，说明我代理了她父亲？这样我至少可以确认她的下落，好让我继续处理她的案子。
OK. For that-- so basically, we don't release that information of the shelter. We can't release that information to the public.
好的。关于这点——基本上，我们不会披露避难所的相关信息。我们不能向公众披露这些信息。
We don't release the information saying what shelter she's in, is what he's saying, right?
他是说他们不会披露女孩所在的避难所信息，对吧？
Right.
对。
Due to safety concerns, safety purposes. But I mean, I can type out a little bit of, like, whatever you want to tell them, tell the shelter, and I can make sure they get the message if that'll work for you.
出于安全考虑。但我可以帮你打印一份你想转达给避难所的消息，我可以确保他们收到，如果这对你有帮助的话。
Yeah, no. I guess I'm just trying to figure out a way that I can explain that I'm an attorney and that I'm the attorney assisting the parent. And the parent has asked me to locate the child. So that way, I can speak with her. Is there any email address that I can maybe send a letter of representation to? Even if it's to someone at your office.
不，不用了。我只是想弄清楚有什么办法能证明我是律师，并且是协助家长的律师。家长已经委托我寻找孩子。这样我就能和她谈谈。有没有什么电子邮件地址可以发送代理委托书？即使是发给你办公室的人也可以。
Give me one second.
请等我一下。
I think that's one of the fundamental problems here, is that they're making it really hard for her to establish that she is, in fact, representing a child.
我认为这是根本问题之一，他们让证明自己确实在代理某个孩子变得非常困难。
And is the parent in the detention center?
家长在拘留中心吗？
Yes. I think you can probably see that in your system, right?
是的。我想你大概可以在系统中看到，对吧？
I can try to find them. But--
我可以试着找一下。但是——
Do you want me to--
需要我——
I was just asking so that--
我只是问一下以便——
Do you want me to confirm his name?
需要我确认他的名字吗？我可以给你。
Huh?
嗯？
Do you want me to confirm the dad's name? I can give that to you.
需要我确认父亲的名字吗？我可以告诉你。
No, it's OK. No, I only have the information for the minors. I don't have the-- for the adults. I mean, I can't go to the ICE locator and find them, but--
不，没关系。我只有未成年人的信息。我没有成人的信息。我不能去ICE的定位系统查找他们，但是——
This surprised me. Is he saying that his database lists the child and where the child is, but doesn't have the parent's name attached to that?
这让我很惊讶。他是说他的数据库里列出了孩子及其位置，但没有关联家长的名字？
Yeah. I mean, he's telling Rochelle that he has no record of even that parent's name, let alone where that parent's located. I mean, and this, I think, is the biggest concern that lawyers have right now is, is there even a record in a government database of which child belongs to which parent? We don't know the answer to that question. But there are a lot of reasons, including this exchange, that would make us think that they don't. They don't know.
是的。他告诉雷切尔，他甚至没有那个家长的记录，更不用说他在哪里了。我想这是目前律师们最担心的问题：政府数据库里是否真的有关于哪个孩子属于哪个家长的记录？我们不知道答案。但有很多理由，包括这次对话，让我们认为他们确实不知道。
So again, so in the recording, he then heads off to try to answer her question about how can she get through to the daughter.
回到录音，他随后去尝试回答她关于如何联系女儿的问题。
OK, I mean, just give me one second so I can speak to my supervisor about this. Let me ask what else I can do for you.
好的，请给我一分钟，让我和主管商量一下。让我问问还能为你做什么。
OK. Thank you, I appreciate that.
好的。谢谢，我很感激。
Do you mind holding on--
介意稍等一下吗——
I do not mind.
我不介意。
--for a little bit? Thank you.
——一会儿吗？谢谢。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Kevin, so on his computer screen he actually has the information that she wants, of where this girl is?
凯文，他的电脑屏幕上其实有她想要的那个女孩位置的信息？
Yeah, that's basically what he's saying, that he has it. He knows where she is, but he can't give it to her.
是的，他基本上就是这么说的，他有这些信息。他知道她在哪，但他不能告诉她。
Now eventually, as this call goes on, the guy gives her an email address. But then it's just the same email address that's on the form that she has, right?
随着通话继续，那人给了她一个电子邮箱。但那只是她表格上已有的那个地址，对吧？
Yeah. Yeah, and I mean, I kind of saw her just entirely deflated after he gave that address.
是的。在他给了那个地址后，我看到她完全泄气了。
Right, so having had it, how do you feel about that call?
好吧，既然经历过，你对那次通话感觉如何？
Not very good.
感觉不太好。
Why?
为什么？
I mean, they're not really trying to help. Yeah. Sorry, it's rough. I just don't know how we're going to track down these kids. That's not helpful. I mean, I can still go through the motions of sending an email to that email address, but I just don't have any faith that it's going to go anywhere.
他们并没有真心想帮忙。抱歉，这很难受。我不知道我们该如何找到这些孩子。这毫无帮助。我可以走个过场给那个地址发邮件，但我根本不相信会有结果。
Sorry, I'm getting emotional. But it's very frustrating. And I can only imagine what's going on on her end.
抱歉，我情绪有点激动。但这太让人沮丧了。我只能想象她那边是什么情况。
OK, so that was a week ago. What's happened since?
好的，那是上周的事了。后来发生了什么？
So, Rochelle reached out to one of the legal service providers who work with children who are detained after crossing the border. And these are organizations that represent children through their deportation proceedings, through their asylum hearings. And these organizations keep track of the kids that they're working with.
雷切尔联系了那些为越境后被拘留的儿童提供服务的法律机构之一。这些组织在遣返诉讼和庇护听证期间为儿童提供代理，并会记录他们代理的孩子。
They each have a list of the kids. And Rochelle kind of got lucky, and the person she reached out to did actually have a record of this girl and was able to tell Rochelle where the girl was being held.
他们每个人都有孩子们的名单。雷切尔很幸运，她联系的那个人确实有这个女孩的记录，并能够告诉雷切尔她被关押在哪里。
She found the name of the shelter?
她找到了避难所的名字？
She found the shelter, yeah. So then the next step was for her to get to the shelter to try to set up basically an appointment. So on Thursday afternoon, she drove to the shelter. And she walked in and there the girl was. I talked to her right afterwards.
是的，她找到了避难所。下一步就是去避难所预约。周四下午，她开车去了那里。她走进去，女孩就在那。我事后立刻和她谈了。
She looked like her dad, so I recognized her right away. I felt-- I felt really emotional about it actually, when I saw her, just because I could see her dad's face in her face. I had to-- obviously, any time you go and you introduce yourself to a child, like they don't know who you are. I obviously explained my relationship to her dad and to her and that I've been looking for her.
她长得像她爸爸，所以我一眼就认出她了。我当时感到非常难过，因为我能在她脸上看到她父亲的影子。显然，每次你去向一个孩子介绍自己，她们都不知道你是谁。我当然向她解释了我与她父亲的关系，以及我一直在寻找她。
And her eyes turned really red when I mentioned her dad. And I asked her if she wanted to write him a letter and she was like, yes. And so she frantically wrote this letter, and I gave her the time to do that.
当我提到她父亲时，她的眼睛变红了。我问她是否想写信给他，她说想。于是她急切地写了这封信，我给了她时间。
And so this girl, she's 12 years old. What did Rochelle say? Is she doing OK?
这个女孩12岁。雷切尔怎么说？她还好吗？
Yeah, the girl's doing OK. Rochelle said she looks healthy. She's wearing a uniform given to her, a sort of polo shirt given to her by the shelter. And she was wearing a bunch of friendship bracelets that I guess she's learned to make there. And then Rochelle had to do this thing, which is explain that this girl probably is not going to see her dad any time soon, and she might not even talk to him any time soon.
是的，女孩还好。雷切尔说她看起来很健康。她穿着避难所发给她的制服，一种POLO衫。她还戴着很多友谊手链，我想是她在那里学会做的。接着雷切尔必须做这件事，那就是向女孩解释，她近期可能无法见到父亲，甚至可能无法和他通话。
The way you explain it is, like, you kind of have to explain what's going on in the national realm, right? You have to say there was this executive order and there was this decision out of the courts, and put it in that kind of context so that-- I mean the thing is, I don't have an answer for her, Kevin. Like, I can't tell her, you're for sure going to get a phone call this day. You're for sure going to be reunited with him on this day. All I can say is, I don't know.
这种解释方式就像是必须解释全国范围内正在发生的事情。你必须说，有这样的行政命令，法院也有这样的裁决，把情况放在那种背景下。问题是，凯文，我没法给她答案。我不能告诉她：“你某天一定会接到电话，你某天一定会和父亲团聚。”我只能说：“我不知道。”
Kevin, I thought the policy had changed. Like, the president announced that we are no longer separating families from children. And in fact, the government announced that they had reunited over 500 children.
凯文，我以为政策已经改变了。总统宣布我们不再将家庭和儿童分开了。事实上，政府还宣布他们已经使500多名儿童与家人团聚。
Yeah, I mean, the government has made these announcements about their plans to reunify families. But when you talk to the lawyers who are representing the parents, nothing has changed at all. And in many cases, not only are the families not reunified, but these lawyers still can't figure out where the children are being held.
政府确实宣布了他们的家庭团聚计划。但当你采访代理父母的律师时，情况一点都没变。在很多情况下，不仅家庭没有团聚，律师们甚至仍然无法查明孩子们被关在哪里。
And what do we know about the 500-plus kids who the government says they reunited?
关于政府声称团聚的那500多名儿童，我们知道什么？
I mean, the government has said that they've reunited these families. When I talk to lawyers who are representing hundreds of parents-- I mean, there's one organization that's representing 376, another that's representing I think over 400 now. I haven't heard of a single-- at least as of a few days ago, I haven't heard of a single reunification.
政府说他们已经促成了团聚。但当我采访那些代理数百名父母的律师时——有一个组织代理了376人，另一个似乎超过400人。我没听说过一个——至少几天前我还没听说过任何成功的团聚案例。
So I mean, I think in the absence of concrete information about who these families were, how they were reunified, lawyers are really wondering if these kids were among the 2,300 who were separated from their parents. If maybe they were from a different pool of children. It's possible that the government numbers are accurate, but there are just so many questions about them, because there's really no documentation that goes along with it.
所以我认为，在缺乏关于这些家庭是谁、如何团聚的明确信息的情况下，律师们真的很怀疑这些孩子是否在当初分离的2300人之中，还是说他们来自另一批孩子。政府的数据可能是准确的，但由于缺乏相应记录，关于这些数据存在太多疑问。
We reached out to the Department of Homeland Security for clarification about all of this, and a spokesperson told us that the 539 children they've said were reunited with parents were all apprehended since May, as part of the administration's zero tolerance policy, and they all were in border patrol custody before being returned to their families. Presumably, being in border patrol custody means they were only in the country a short time and had never been transferred to other agencies, shelters, and foster homes. The spokesperson declined to provide any names of these families or any information about what countries they were from.
我们联系了国土安全部寻求澄清，一位发言人告诉我们，他们所说的已团聚的539名儿童都是自五月起，作为“零容忍”政策的一部分被逮捕的，并且在被送还家人前都处于边境巡逻队的羁押下。据推测，处于边境巡逻队羁押意味着他们进入美国的时间很短，从未被转移到其他机构、避难所或寄养家庭。发言人拒绝提供这些家庭的名字，也拒绝提供关于他们来自哪些国家的信息。
But this kind of situation where somebody-- in this case, the President of the United States-- declares that he's changed-- it's all different, he's moving on, no longer separating kids from their parents, but the result is not so clear. That situation, that is what our show is about today. Something happens, maybe you'd like to believe it's true, but you don't know if you should.
但这种有人——在本案中是美国总统——宣称他已经改变、一切都不同了，他正在前进、不再将孩子与父母分开，但结果却并不明确的情况，正是我们今天节目要探讨的主题。事情发生了，你或许愿意相信它是真的，但你不知道是否应该相信。
We have a bunch of different stories that do not involve the current administration, or any previous ones. One of the stories, in fact, takes us into a noisy world of half-clad soap opera stars and daytime TV hosts, none of whom I bet you have ever heard of. Stay with us.
我们还有很多不涉及现任政府或任何前任政府的故事。事实上，其中一个故事把我们带进了一个喧闹的世界，那里满是衣着暴露的肥皂剧明星和日间节目主持人，我敢说你一个都没听说过。请留下来。
Act One, The All Too Real Housewives of Argentina. There's an old saying, don't believe everything you see. But there's a corollary, of course-- don't believe everything you see on TV, especially daytime TV. And it doesn't matter what country you're in. Jasmine Garsd grew up in Argentina and has this story.
第一幕，阿根廷最真实的家庭主妇。有句老话，别相信你看到的每件事。当然还有个推论——别相信电视上看到的每件事，尤其是日间电视节目。无论你在哪个国家都一样。洁丝敏·加尔德在阿根廷长大，她有这个故事。
Quick warning before we start-- the stories in today's show have some curse words that we have un-beeped here in the podcast version of the show. If you want a version with beeps, maybe you're listening with kids, go to our website. And here's Jasmine.
在开始前做一个简短警告——今天节目中的故事包含一些脏话，我们在播客版中没有消音。如果你想要消音版，或者你正带着孩子收听，请去我们的网站。这是洁丝敏。
I watched a lot of television when I was a kid. My grandmother, Iaia, would pick me up at school and bring me back to her place. Her apartment was dark and humid. It smelled like French bread and the exhaust from the buses on the avenue down below. My grandfather was never around.
我小时候看很多电视。我的祖母，也就是Iaia，会从学校接我回家。她的公寓阴暗潮湿。闻起来有法棍面包味，还有楼下大街上巴士的尾气味。我的祖父从不在家。
Iaia would make tea and then we would go to her bedroom and turn the TV on. And suddenly, colors, sound, and sex would pour into the world. It was the early afternoon. It was time for the talk shows.
Iaia会泡茶，然后我们去卧室打开电视。瞬间，色彩、声音和色情涌入世界。那是午后。是谈话节目的时间。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
Argentine talk shows are extreme, even for Latin American television. The women are pumped up with silicone and Botox, and sometimes show up wearing almost nothing. The conversation is not just double entendres, but straight up entendres, full-on vulgar language. When I was growing up, it was a parade of pasties, stilettos, feather boas.
阿根廷的谈话节目极其夸张，即便在拉丁美洲电视圈也是如此。女人们注射了大量硅胶和肉毒杆菌，有时出场时几乎什么都没穿。谈话内容不仅有双关语，更是直白的、充满庸俗语言的内容。在我成长过程中，那简直是一场乳贴、高跟鞋和羽毛围巾的游行。
One of the most popular shows back then was hosted by a guy named Jorge Rial. He's still on TV. He's kind of the Argentine everyman-- charming and a little bit of a hustler. These days, his TV show is called Intrusos, or Intruders.
当时最火的节目之一是由一个叫豪尔赫·里亚尔的人主持的。他现在还在电视上。他就像阿根廷的平民偶像——迷人，带点投机色彩。这些年，他的节目叫《Intrusos》，意为《入侵者》。
It takes place on a set that is just seizure inducing-- neon colors, walls lined with giant video screens. Jorge Rial likes to stir up fights among his voluptuous guests. Every time something shocking is said, ominous music rolls out.
节目的场景布置极其刺激感官——霓虹灯色，墙上挂着巨大的视频屏幕。豪尔赫·里亚尔喜欢在他那些丰满的嘉宾中挑起争斗。每次说出什么令人震惊的话，就会配上不祥的音乐。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
[OMINOUS MUSIC PLAYING]
[不祥的音乐播放]
Once in a while, a woman is so sexy that Jorge Rial bites his lower lip and mugs for the camera. This has been Rial's style for years. Back in the day, Iaia would bring the tea and cookies and lie down next to me in her patent leather platform shoes, which she never took off, not even in bed. My grandmother was the target audience for Rial's show, what's commonly known as "doña rosa," a housewife.
偶尔，如果有女人太性感，豪尔赫·里亚尔会咬住下唇对镜头做鬼脸。这是里亚尔多年的风格。过去，Iaia会拿来茶和饼干，穿着她那双漆皮厚底鞋躺在我旁边，她从不脱鞋，连睡觉都不脱。我的祖母正是里亚尔节目的目标受众，也就是通常所说的“doña rosa”，家庭主妇。
She loved to hate the show, to look disapprovingly at the women and comment how much surgery she's had. "Una prostituta," a prostitute. "una loca." And they give her expensive gifts-- cars, vacations. And I'd look around me my grandmother's lonely apartment and think to myself, wow. That sounds pretty amazing. I knew I didn't want to be a doña rosa when I grew up.
她喜欢边看边讨厌这节目，不屑地看着那些女人并评论她们整了多少容。“妓女，”她说，“疯子。”节目给她们昂贵的礼物——车、假期。我环顾祖母孤独的公寓，心里想，哇。那听起来真棒。我知道长大后我不想成为“doña rosa”。
When I was a teenager, I moved to the US and eventually became a journalist. I've lived here for 15 years. Sometimes when I get homesick, I stream Intrusos on YouTube. I leave it on when I cook and clean. When I watch it, I'm not 5,000 miles away. Iaia is alive, nothing has changed much. Nothing ever changes on Argentine daytime TV. Until suddenly, a few months ago, it did.
十几岁时我搬到了美国，最终成为了一名记者。我已经在这儿住了15年。有时想家了，我会在YouTube上流媒体看《Intrusos》。做饭和打扫时我都会开着。看它的时候，我不觉得身处5000英里外。Iaia还活着，什么都没变多少。阿根廷日间电视节目从不改变。直到几个月前，突然变了。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
One night in February, I was at home in New York cleaning my kitchen. Intrusos was on in the background and I heard this woman with a raspy Lauren Bacall voice. I turned around, soapy sponge in hand, and squinted at the screen-- a tattooed, heavyset woman wearing sneakers.
二月的一天晚上，我在纽约家里清理厨房。《Intrusos》在后台播放，我听到一个有着劳伦·白考尔般沙哑嗓音的女人的声音。我拿着海绵转过身，眯眼看着屏幕——一个纹身、身材魁梧、穿着运动鞋的女人。
I recognized this woman, a comedian named Senorita Bimbo. The stage name, Bimbo, is ironic. She's anything but. In fact, the very next thing she did was look directly into the camera and offer a statistic about illegal abortions.
我认出了她，一个叫Senorita Bimbo的喜剧演员。“Bimbo”（花瓶）这个艺名很讽刺。她绝非如此。事实上，她做的下一件事就是直视镜头，提供了一个关于非法堕胎的统计数据。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
"500,000 women in Argentina have illegal abortions every year," she said. She was wearing a bright green handkerchief around her neck, a provocative symbol everyone in Argentina knows-- the symbol of the fight to legalize abortion. For years, activists have been pushing to get Congress to vote on it.
“阿根廷每年有50万名女性进行非法堕胎，”她说。她的脖子上围着一条鲜艳的绿手帕，这是阿根廷每个人都知道的挑衅性标志——象征着堕胎合法化的斗争。多年来，活动家们一直在推动国会对此进行投票。
When I was growing up, abortion was something you just didn't talk about in Argentina, a Catholic country. It's still not something that comes up on daytime TV. Reproductive rights? That's just not Intrusos material. Though here was Jorge Rial, the host, looking intently at Senorita Bimbo.
我成长过程中，在阿根廷这个天主教国家，堕胎是不被谈论的话题。它至今也不是日间电视节目的素材。生殖权利？那根本不是《Intrusos》的内容。但豪尔赫·里亚尔这位主持人正盯着Senorita Bimbo。
A few hours later, one of my best friends texted me, "Did you watch Intrusos today?" I sat down at my laptop and started scrolling through the descriptions of the last few episodes. The guests were names I knew-- academics, writers, comedians. What they had in common was, they were all feminists, people who have been on the fringes for years, criticizing sexism in Argentina and demanding women's rights.
几个小时后，我最好的朋友给我发短信：“你今天看《Intrusos》了吗？”我坐在笔记本电脑前，开始滚动浏览过去几集的描述。嘉宾名单里有我熟悉的名字——学者、作家、喜剧演员。他们的共同点是都是女权主义者，都是多年来边缘化的人物，批评阿根廷的性别歧视并要求女性权利。
I started binge watching. In each episode, there was a nuanced conversation about feminism. Rial looked kind of meek, but not in his usual, "I've been overpowered by sexy ladies" way. He kept delivering these really impassioned monologues saying, I don't want to be a misogynist, a "machista." I'm a recovering machista.
我开始狂看。每一集中，都有关于女权主义的微妙对话。里亚尔看起来很温顺，但不是那种通常的“被性感女士压倒”的样子。他一直发表充满激情的独白，说：“我不想成为一个厌女者，一个‘大男子主义者’。我是一个正在康复中的大男子主义者。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
The Argentine everyman now appeared to be an earnest feminist. This was not the Rial I grew up with. This was not the TV I grew up with. What happened? Could this possibly be sincere? I flew to Argentina to find out.
这位阿根廷平民偶像现在看起来是个真诚的女权主义者。这不是我长大的那个里亚尔。这不是我长大的那种电视。发生了什么？这可能是真心的吗？我飞往阿根廷一探究竟。
As soon as I got there, I went to the studios where Intrusos is taped. I met Ana Laura Guevara, one of the show's executive producers.
一到那，我就去了《Intrusos》的录制工作室。我见到了执行制片人之一，安娜·劳拉·格瓦拉。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
Being live involves a lot of adrenalin. I really, really love the adrenalin.
现场直播需要大量的肾上腺素。我真的、真的很爱那种肾上腺素。
To be honest, I wasn't expecting an Intrusos executive producer to be a woman, especially not one like Ana Laura, a self-proclaimed feminist. I had a really hard time wrapping my head around the fact that, for 18 years, she had been behind this totally trashy and objectifying show. Ana Laura told me, it's just a job, one she's good at. It's intensely competitive.
老实说，我没料到《Intrusos》的执行制片人会是个女人，尤其不是像安娜·劳拉这样自称女权主义者的人。我很难接受一个事实，那就是在过去的18年里，她一直在这个完全低俗且物化女性的节目背后操盘。安娜·劳拉说，这只是一份工作，一份她擅长的工作。而且竞争极其激烈。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
In the control room, her face shines from the light of the monitor she's hunched over, like in a casino-- a monitor that, minute by minute, tracks the ratings for Intrusos and every other show that's on the air at the same time. I had no idea this was possible. Right now on Intrusos, there's a fight between a former cabaret dancer and a potential candidate for president.
在控制室里，她的脸被显示器的光照亮，像是在赌场一样——那台监控器每分钟都在追踪《Intrusos》和同时段其他节目的收视率。我不知道这竟然是可能的。此刻《Intrusos》正在上演一场前歌舞女郎和潜在总统候选人之间的争吵。
This, like, skyrocketed. The ratings are going up with this segment. It's like four points-- it went from 4.0 to 4.6. This is doing better than the news.
这简直飞涨。收视率随着这个片段而上升。从4.0点涨到了4.6点。这比新闻还好。
Next segment, a fashion model from the '80s says she has her suspicions about a designer's recent death.
下一片段，一位80年代的时尚模特说她对一位设计师最近的去世持怀疑态度。
It dipped to 3.4.
降到了3.4。
The ratings plummet. Nobody cares. Ana Laura orders them to end the segment early. Interest lags for an instant, and Intrusos moves on.
收视率暴跌。没人关心。安娜·劳拉命令他们提前结束片段。兴趣瞬间消失，《Intrusos》继续播放下一个内容。
The story of how the feminists intruded into Intrusos is its own soap opera. There are a gazillion gossip shows in Argentina. It's like this whole universe. Back in January, one of the shows interviewed this famous singer, a leathery guy in a tropical shirt. In the middle of the interview, the singer casually repeats this awful saying I used to hear as a kid-- if someone wants to rape you, relax and enjoy it.
女权主义者如何入侵《Intrusos》的故事本身就是一出肥皂剧。阿根廷有成千上万的八卦节目。这是一个完整的宇宙。回到一月，其中一个节目采访了一位著名的歌手，一个穿着热带衬衫、皮肤粗糙的男人。在采访中，歌手随意地重复了我小时候常听到的那句糟糕的谚语——如果有人想强奸你，放松享受吧。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
The first time I heard that was when I was nine years old. I was in the locker room and a girl blurted it out. I thought it was advice. A lot of my friends did, too.
我第一次听到那是九岁时。我在更衣室里，一个女孩冲口而出。我以为那是建议。我的很多朋友也这么以为。
So the singer says this offensive thing. A few days later, on another talk show, a soap opera star blows up about it. Her name is Araceli Gonzales.
所以歌手说了那句冒犯的话。几天后，在另一个谈话节目里，一位肥皂剧明星对此爆发了。她的名字叫阿拉塞利·冈萨雷斯。
When I was a kid, her soap opera was huge. She played a mute. A hunk with feathered hair would talk at her while she listened tearfully. But now she wasn't mute. She said the singer's remark made her sick.
小时候，她的肥皂剧火得不得了。她扮演一个哑巴。一个留着羽毛发型、肌肉发达的男人对着她说话，而她含泪倾听。但现在她不再沉默。她说歌手的评论让她恶心。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
It was kind of beautiful seeing her get angry after so many years of playing a character literally defined by silence. Ana Laura, from Intrusos, saw the fight happening on TV and she wanted to get a piece of it. She booked Araceli to come on the show.
在多年扮演一个以沉默为定义的角色后，看到她发火真是一种美感。《Intrusos》的安娜·劳拉看到了电视上的这场争吵，她想分一杯羹。她预约了阿拉塞利来节目。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
It was a typical day on Intrusos. Jorge Rial talked about how much granny panties used to turn him on as a kid. Two former showgirls argued. And then it was Araceli's turn. And just because Araceli had gotten mad about the rape comment, one of the panelists introduces her as a feminist. As soon as Araceli got a chance, she corrected him.
那是《Intrusos》典型的一天。豪尔赫·里亚尔谈论小时候奶奶的内裤是如何让他兴奋的。两位前舞女在争吵。然后轮到阿拉塞利了。就因为阿拉塞利对强奸评论发了火，其中一位小组成员介绍她为女权主义者。阿拉塞利一有机会，就纠正了他。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
She says, "I heard you refer to me as a feminist just now, and I am not a feminist." She is vehemently wagging her finger as she says this.
她说：“我刚听到你称我为女权主义者，我不是女权主义者。”她在说这话时激烈地摇着手指。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
"I have a wonderful husband and a lovely son whom I love very much, and I respect men." This set off another firestorm. Here's Ana Laura.
“我有一个很棒的丈夫和一个我深爱的可爱儿子，我尊重男人。”这又引发了一场风暴。这是安娜·劳拉说的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
So people started tweeting about it. And we saw that feminists started to respond. So everything exploded.
于是人们开始在推特上讨论。我们看到女权主义者开始回应。于是炸了锅了。
There were the kinds of tweets you would expect like, quote, "What the fuck does loving your husband and son have to do with being a feminist, you moron?" And here it was, feminists versus the soap opera star, a fight made for daytime television.
推文全是意料之中的那种，比如，“爱你的丈夫和儿子和你是不是女权主义者有什么关系，你这个白痴？”这就是女权主义者对阵肥皂剧明星，一场为日间电视而生的争斗。
And Ana Laura knew it. And she also knew Jorge Rial, the host of the show-- something had been changing with him lately. Like, he'd been saying to anyone who would listen--
安娜·劳拉知道这一点。她也了解《Intrusos》的主持人豪尔赫·里亚尔——他最近有些改变。就像他一直在对任何人说——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
I am a machista in recovery. I'm trying to find myself.
我是一个正在康复中的大男子主义者。我正在寻找自我。
So she approached him in the dressing room and they started talking. Maybe we should have a feminist on the show to explain what feminism is.
所以她在化妆间找到了他，他们开始交谈。也许我们应该请一位女权主义者上节目解释什么是女权主义。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
We hadn't discussed that beforehand. But this day on the dressing room, I think that he was really into it.
我们之前没讨论过。但在化妆间的那天，我想他真的很感兴趣。
They decided on a well-known feminist academic, Flor Freijo. And even she'll tell you she's a safe bet for a show like Intrusos. She's thin and blonde. So Flor gets invited to Intrusos and the very first question Jorge Rial asks her is, what is feminism?
他们定了一位著名的女权主义学者，弗洛尔·弗雷霍。即便她自己也会告诉你，对于《Intrusos》这样的节目来说，她是稳妥的选择。她瘦削、金发。所以弗洛尔受邀来到《Intrusos》，豪尔赫·里亚尔问她的第一个问题就是：什么是女权主义？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
I didn't prepare anything. I didn't prepare a speech. I didn't have time. So I went open to listen to the questions and explain things just as I do to my students in a class.
我没准备任何东西。我没准备演讲稿。我没时间。所以我开放地去听那些问题，就像我在课堂上给学生解释一样。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
Of all the strange things I'd seen on Argentine TV, this might be one of the oddest. Against a neon fizz background, Flor Freijo does a feminism 101. At the bottom of the screen, a banner in bold letters reads, "Feminism-- it's a movement for women's rights." Flor starts explaining, feminism is a movement for women's rights. It started in the 19th century. It has to do with the division of labor, child rearing. Jorge Rial is listening, completely mesmerized, his little eyebrows furrowed, scratching his beard. And while all this is happening, Ana Laura is sitting in the control room upstairs, watching everything, of course-- and also keeping her eye on the ratings monitor. The control room is usually a chaotic mess of yelling, but now, with Flor speaking--
在阿根廷电视上我见过的所有奇怪的事情中，这可能是最奇怪的之一。在霓虹灯背景前，弗洛尔·弗雷霍进行了一次女权主义入门讲座。屏幕下方，一个加粗的横幅写着：“女权主义——这是一场争取妇女权利的运动。”弗洛尔开始解释，女权主义是争取妇女权利的运动。它始于19世纪。它与劳动分工、育儿有关。豪尔赫·里亚尔听着，完全入迷了，眉毛皱起，抓着胡子。而当这一切发生时，安娜·劳拉正坐在楼上的控制室里，当然也在观察这一切——同时也盯着收视率监测器。控制室通常是一片嘈杂混乱，但现在，弗洛尔说话时——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
And when we were watching her talking, Flor, the control room went quiet. We were all paying attention to what she was saying. But we were all quiet. We were really like, silently watching and learning from her.
当我们看着弗洛尔谈话时，控制室安静了下来。我们都在注意听她说的内容。我们都很安静。我们真的像是在默默地学习。
And then the spell is broken because the phone rings in the control room. It's Araceli, the soap opera star who's the whole reason Flora's here. She wants to talk to Flor live, right now. Everyone in the control room is geared up for a good old-fashioed Intrusos spat.
然后咒语被打破了，因为控制室电话响了。是阿拉塞利，那个让弗洛尔来到这里的肥皂剧明星。她现在就要现场和弗洛尔通话。控制室里的每个人都准备好迎接一场老式《Intrusos》风格的争吵。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
Flor was kind of shocked.
弗洛尔有点震惊。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
I didn't know that Araceli was going to call. I had no idea of what was going to happen.
我不知道阿拉塞利会打电话。我不知道会发生什么。
But it wasn't an ambush. Araceli wasn't calling to fight. Instead she tells Flor, I've been listening really well to what you're saying. And she wanted the audience to know that she didn't know what feminism was until just now, when she was watching TV and saw Flor explain it.
但这并非埋伏。阿拉塞利打电话不是为了吵架。相反，她告诉弗洛尔：“我一直在认真听你说的。我想让观众知道，我刚才看电视看到弗洛尔解释之前，根本不知道女权主义是什么。”
She starts telling the story of her life through various generations of women, her own single mother and herself. She talks about how she had been sexually abused as a child and emotionally abused as an adult. And Araceli told Flor, I know what you're talking about and I agree with you. If this means being a feminist, then I'm a feminist.
她开始讲述自己通过几代女性——她单身的母亲和她自己——的生活故事。她谈到童年时曾被性虐待，成年后被情感虐待。阿拉塞利告诉弗洛尔：“我知道你在谈论什么，我同意你。如果这就是成为女权主义者的含义，那我是女权主义者。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
Flor nods, and gives a thumbs up. By the way, this is never how Intrusos finishes. People don't just listen to each other and change their minds. And the ratings-- Ana Laura says the ratings were great, strong enough that she decided, let's do this again tomorrow. And so it began.
弗洛尔点头，竖起大拇指。顺便说一句，这可不是《Intrusos》典型的结束方式。人们不会只是听对方说话然后改变主意。至于收视率——安娜·劳拉说收视率很棒，好到她决定：“明天再做一次。”于是它开始了。
[OMINOUS MUSIC PLAYING]
[不祥的音乐播放]
Over the next few days, some of the most famous feminists in Argentina came onto Intrusos. Comedians, authors, professors-- audiences were stunned. Someone tweeted, "My ideology is starting to converge with Jorge Rial's, and that terrifies me." It was pretty strange for everyone. This very misogynistic show had suddenly become like, the public town hall on feminism in Argentina. And the ratings were not just good. Ana Laura says they were higher than normal. She was delighted that she could keep this going.
接下来的几天，阿根廷一些最著名的女权主义者来到《Intrusos》。喜剧演员、作家、教授——观众们惊呆了。有人发推特：“我的意识形态开始与豪尔赫·里亚尔趋同，这让我很害怕。”这对每个人来说都很奇怪。这个非常厌女的节目突然变成了阿根廷关于女权主义的公共市政厅。收视率不仅很好。安娜·劳拉说比平时更高。她很高兴能继续这样做。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
There's a journalist called Luciana Baker. She is also very important in feminism and she's an old friend from college. And she came to our show. And when we met backstage we were like, not even in our wildest dreams we could have dreamt about this, you being here in this type of show.
有个叫卢西亚娜·贝克的记者。她在女权主义中也非常重要，她是我的老同学。她来到我们的节目。我们在后台见面时说，我们甚至在最疯狂的梦里也想不到，你会来到这样的节目。
Midway through all of this is when I tuned in, when I started streaming in New York. The show was like, going through hundreds of years of feminism in a couple of days. They passed through topics like LGBT rights, workplace harassment, income inequality. And then the most taboo thing of all-- abortion.
这一切进行到一半时我收看了节目，我在纽约开始流媒体收看。节目就像是在几天内经历了数百年的女权主义历史。他们谈论了LGBT权利、职场骚扰、收入不平等。然后是所有禁忌中最禁忌的话题——堕胎。
Jorge Rial tied the green handkerchief around his wrist, the one activists who want to legalize abortion wear. And then he invited the large woman with the gravelly voice who I saw at home in New York City, Senorita Bimbo. Right off the bat she said, the fact that there's a fat girl on Argentine TV is already a victory.
豪尔赫·里亚尔在手腕上系了绿色手帕，那是想要堕胎合法化的活动家戴的。然后他邀请了我在纽约家里看到的那个声音沙哑的高大女性，Senorita Bimbo。她上来就说，阿根廷电视上有个胖女孩本身就是一场胜利。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
She told me she was actually pretty nervous.
她告诉我其实当时很紧张。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
The first thing I thought was, what they're all going to say is like, what is this fat girl doing here, this fat girl feminazi?
我脑子里的第一个念头是，他们都会说：“这个胖女孩在这里干什么，这个胖女孩女权纳粹？”
But she powered through. She had a mission.
但她坚持下来了。她有使命。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
I knew I wanted to talk about abortion. My plan was to at least mention it. And I just sat down and started talking. I felt like I was going to battle, where I had to use words as arrows, because abortion is something that you don't say. It's something that you talk about in hushed tones if you have one.
我知道我想谈论堕胎。我的计划是至少提到它。我只是坐下来开始谈。感觉就像要上战场，我必须用言语作为箭，因为堕胎是不能说的事情。如果你有这种经历，那是只能在耳边低语的事情。
On Intrusos, Senorita Bimbo talked about how abortion is so taboo, you don't even talk about it in fiction. In Argentine TV and film, unwanted pregnancy is solved by a villain pushing you down the stairs and causing you to miscarry.
在《Intrusos》上，Senorita Bimbo谈到堕胎是多么禁忌，甚至在小说里都不敢提。在阿根廷的电视和电影里，意外怀孕的解决方法是一个反派把你推下楼梯导致流产。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
And then about 30 seconds before they cut to commercial and moved to the next guest, Senorita Bimbo said something about abortion that surprised even her.
然后在大约广告前30秒，转移到下一个嘉宾前，Senorita Bimbo说了关于堕胎的一句话，连她自己都惊讶了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
Misoprostol-- she says, I want girls to know about misoprostol. This is a really big deal. Officially, misoprostol is a drug used to treat stomach ulcers, but it can also be used to induce labor. So in a continent where abortion is mostly banned, women take it if they want to miscarry. People call it the DIY abortion. She's talking about doing something illegal on one of the most popular daytime talk shows, watched by housewives. That same day, misoprostol was one of the most Googled words in the country. "I think you're underestimating your audience," Senorita Bimbo said on the show. Doña rosa is dead-- doña rosa, that stereotypical Argentine housewife.
“米索前列醇，”她说，“我想让女孩们知道米索前列醇。”这是一件大事。正式来说，米索前列醇是一种治疗胃溃疡的药物，但它也可以用来诱导分娩。所以在堕胎大多被禁止的大洲，女性如果想流产会吃它。人们称之为DIY堕胎。她在收视率最高的日间谈话节目之一，在家庭主妇们的注视下，谈论做违法的事情。就在那天，米索前列醇成了全国搜索次数最多的词。“我想你们低估了自己的观众，”Senorita Bimbo在节目上说。“Doña rosa”死了——那个典型的阿根廷家庭主妇。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
So the woman that is in front of the TV, and who needs her world to be explained to her through daytime TV, she just doesn't exist anymore.
所以那个坐在电视前，需要通过日间电视来解释世界的女人，她根本不存在了。
Of course, none of this would have happened on Intrusos if the ratings had been bad. And the ratings were great for reasons that Jorge Rial and Ana Laura can claim no credit for at all. Feminism has been gaining critical mass in Argentina for the last couple of years. The movement was triggered by these brutal murders of young women, often by boyfriends, husbands, and fathers.
当然，如果收视率很差，这一切都不会在《Intrusos》上发生。收视率之所以好，豪尔赫·里亚尔和安娜·劳拉完全无法居功。在过去几年里，女权主义在阿根廷一直在积累临界质量。这场运动是由年轻女性被男友、丈夫和父亲残忍谋杀所触发的。
Women started protesting. A whole crusade was born. It was called Ni Una Menos, not one less woman. And since 2015, this has grown to the point where it's impossible to ignore and has expanded to abortion rights, street harassment, and equal pay.
女性开始抗议。一场完整的运动诞生了。它叫“Ni Una Menos”，意为“少一个女性也不行”。自2015年以来，它已增长到无法忽视的地步，并扩展到堕胎权、街头骚扰和平等薪酬。
It's young people on social media, comedians on YouTube, pop stars on Instagram, gigantic demonstrations. It just wasn't a topic for daytime talk shows until Jorge, Ana Laura, and Intrusos.
它是社交媒体上的年轻人、YouTube上的喜剧演员、Instagram上的流行歌星、巨大的示威活动。直到豪尔赫、安娜·劳拉和《Intrusos》，这在日间谈话节目里一直不是话题。
During that week on Intrusos, there was this explosion of tweets from young girls perplexed but ecstatic to see feminism on daytime TV. This one girl, Anita Ocampo tweeted, "I showed my dad the Intrusos episode with Senorita Bimbo." I dropped by her house and she told me, these feminists were explaining to Jorge Rial all the things she'd tried to explain but couldn't get her parents to understand. So one night she approached her dad.
在那周《Intrusos》播出期间，社交媒体上涌现出一堆困惑但欣喜若狂的推文，那是年轻女孩们看到女权主义出现在日间电视上时的反应。有个女孩安妮塔·奥坎波发推：“我向我爸爸展示了Senorita Bimbo那集的《Intrusos》。”我去了她家，她说这些女权主义者正在向豪尔赫·里亚尔解释她尝试解释却无法让父母理解的所有事情。所以有一天晚上她去找爸爸。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
And she told him, if you watch this episode of Intrusos on YouTube with me, I'll massage your feet. She ended up getting the whole family to watch. She showed them Senorita Bimbo. She pointed to Jorge Rial wearing the same green handkerchief she wears and said, look, it's just like mine.
她告诉他，如果你和我一起在YouTube上看这集《Intrusos》，我就帮你按摩脚。她最终让全家都看了。她展示了Senorita Bimbo。她指着戴着和她一样绿色手帕的豪尔赫·里亚尔说：“看，这和我的一样。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
It opened up a conversation, which she says they've been having ever since. Anita's mom says she saw Jorge Rial talk about how he's a recovering chauvinist and she says, so is she.
这开启了一段对话，她说他们从此一直在交流。安妮塔的妈妈说她看到豪尔赫·里亚尔谈论自己是一个康复中的大男子主义者，她说她也是。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
I'm at, like, 70% feminism, she says. I still have 30% left to go.
“我大概有70%的女权主义了，”她说，“还有30%要走。”
During my week in Argentina I kept trying to talk to Jorge Rial, and he kept blowing me off. Had he really converted to feminism? Everyone I asked rolled their eyes and pointed to the last few decades of his career. They pointed to his recent vicious public fight with one of his daughters. They pointed to how late he is to the whole feminism thing. He's a Johnny come lately. He's only doing this because it will make him more popular. After days of giving me the runaround, he told me to just send my questions. And finally, on my very last night in Argentina, my phone lit up. It was voice memos from Jorge Rial.
在阿根廷的那周，我一直尝试和豪尔赫·里亚尔谈话，但他一直拒绝。他真的皈依了女权主义吗？我问过的每个人都翻白眼，并指着他过去几十年的职业生涯。他们指着他最近与女儿之一恶毒的公开争吵。他们指着他介入女权主义有多晚。他是个“迟来的约翰尼”。他做这些只是为了让自己更受欢迎。经过几天推诿，他让我把问题发过去。终于，在阿根廷的最后一晚，我的手机亮了。是豪尔赫·里亚尔的语音备忘录。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
"What happened to me?" Rial says. "What made me bring all these feminists onto Intrusos?"
“我发生了什么？”里亚尔说。“是什么让我把这些女权主义者带上《Intrusos》？”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
He talks about his 18-year-old daughter, Rosio, and how she's a feminist. "We have these very interesting talks over dinner," he says, "And she started opening this world up to me. I am 56 years old. I was raised in a completely sexist culture and I didn't get it. That's why I say I'm a recovering chauvinist, thanks to my daughter. My daughter made me change."
他谈到他18岁的女儿罗西奥，以及她是如何成为女权主义者的。“我们在晚餐时进行了一些非常有趣的对话，”他说，“她开始向我打开这个世界。我已经56岁了。我在完全性别歧视的文化中长大，我不懂这些。这就是为什么我说我是一个正在康复的大男子主义者，多亏了我女儿。我女儿让我改变了。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
Jorge Rial knows that I think Intrusos is stupid. He knows most people do. That's the show's superpower.
豪尔赫·里亚尔知道我觉得《Intrusos》很愚蠢。他知道大多数人都这么觉得。那是节目的超能力。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
"Frívolo--" we're frivolous. We're a show about showbiz. No one suspected that this is where feminism could win. We eluded the firewalls that kept feminism off of TV. There was this wall, you couldn't talk about these things on TV.
“Frívolo——”我们很轻浮。我们是一个展示秀。没人怀疑这就是女权主义可以赢的地方。我们绕过了那些将女权主义挡在电视之外的防火墙。曾经有一堵墙，你在电视上不能谈论这些事情。
And suddenly it happened on Intrusos. "But to be honest," he said, "it's all because of feminists. They knew any place is good, if you have a strong message."
突然它在《Intrusos》上发生了。“但说实话，”他说，“这全是因为女权主义者。只要有强有力的信息，她们知道任何地方都是好地方。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
After the week of feminism, Intrusos was left with a split personality. These days, it's a mix of fighting starlets and women's rights activists. Jorge Rial's social media is a mix of World Cup woes, celebrity gossip, and then these really earnest feminist tweets.
在那一周的女权主义节目之后，《Intrusos》留下了一个分裂的人格。这些天，它是斗争中的明星和女权活动家的混合体。豪尔赫·里亚尔的社交媒体是世界杯的悲伤、名人八卦，然后是这些真正认真的女权主义推文的混合物。
Like this one a few weeks ago-- "They came to make things better for the coming generations, for our daughters and their daughters, and also for men. The men who come after us must be better than us. We did everything wrong."
就像几周前的这条——“她们是为了让后代变得更好而来，为了我们的女儿和她们的女儿，也为了男人。我们之后的男人必须比我们更好。我们把一切都搞砸了。”
The day after he tweeted that on June 14, Argentina's lower house of Congress approved a bill to legalize abortion. After an all-night debate, it barely passed by only four votes. And it yet has to pass the upper house. Still, outside Congress, thousands of women and activists who'd gathered to wait for the results celebrated wildly.
在他发出那条推文的次日，6月14日，阿根廷国会众议院批准了一项堕胎合法化法案。经过整夜辩论，仅以四票优势通过。它还必须通过参议院。尽管如此，在国会外，数千名聚集等待结果的女性和活动家欣喜若狂。
Every time I spoke to those women about what role television like Intrusos played in all this, they got uncomfortable. On my last day in Argentina I grabbed a coffee with an old friend from high school, Jordana Timerman. She recently wrote an op-ed for the New York Times about the push to legalize abortion in Argentina, and we talked about the role pop culture played in that.
每当我与那些女性谈论《Intrusos》之类的电视在这一切中扮演的角色时，她们就会感到不安。在阿根廷的最后一天，我和高中老友乔丹娜·蒂默曼一起喝咖啡。她最近在《纽约时报》写了一篇关于阿根廷推动堕胎合法化的专栏，我们谈到了流行文化在其中的作用。
You need to have people like Rial, or pop culture, doña rosa, understanding that this is a necessary right. Because if not, it's not going to happen.
你需要有像里亚尔这样的人，或者流行文化、doña rosa，理解这是一个必要的权利。因为如果不这样，它就不会发生。
In other words, the message needs to go into homes in the most remote locations of the country. And TV is one of the only ways to do that. Jordana was saying Intrusos helped. But when I asked her about whether we should thank Jorge Rial, she just laughs.
换句话说，信息需要进入该国最偏远地区的家庭。电视是做到这一点的唯一途径。乔丹娜说《Intrusos》帮了大忙。但当我问她我们是否应该感谢豪尔赫·里亚尔时，她只是笑了。
I'm not going on record with that. Are you crazy? I have a name.
我可不会录音说那个。你疯了吗？我还有名声呢。
I know what she means. After so many years of awful television and this guy's shenanigans, I just don't want to tip my hat to him. And maybe that's part of his penance. He did something good and no one will ever thank him for it.
我知道她的意思。在多年的糟糕电视和这个人的恶作剧之后，我只是不想向他致敬。也许那是他苦修的一部分。他做了一件好事，但永远不会有人感谢他。
Jasmine Garsd, she's an NPR reporter. This story was co-produced with Marianne McCune as part of a collaboration with the NPR podcast, Rough Translation. If you have not heard that show, the premise is they look at how things we talk about here in the United States get talked about elsewhere around the world.
洁丝敏·加尔德，她是NPR记者。这个故事是与玛丽安·麦昆联合制作的，作为与NPR播客《Rough Translation》合作的一部分。如果你没听过那个节目，其前提是看看我们在美国谈论的事情在世界其他地方是如何被谈论的。
This leads into all kinds of stories that take you deep into other cultures and countries in this way. This is very unusual. Rough Translation, find it at Apple podcasts or the nine million other places you can get a podcast these days.
这导致了各种各样的故事，将你深入带入其他文化和国家。这非常罕见。《Rough Translation》，在Apple Podcasts或你现在可以获取播客的其他九百万个地方找到它。
[MUSIC - "MACHISTA" BY BUFFALO MOON]
[音乐 - “MACHISTA” BY BUFFALO MOON]
Coming up, OK, you've heard about good cop, bad cop. But what about a bad cop who now says he's a good cop, and really, really, really, really wants everybody to believe him? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，好吧，你听说过好警察、坏警察。但如果有一个说自己现在是好警察的坏警察，而且非常、非常、非常、非常想让每个人都相信他，那会怎样？那是来自芝加哥公共广播电台，一分钟后节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Change You Can Maybe Believe In. We have stories where things happen that you want to believe, you wish you could believe, but something tells you maybe you should not believe. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, You Have The Right To Remain Angry.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，关于你可以也许去相信的改变。我们有这样的故事：发生了你想相信、你希望你能相信的事情，但某种东西告诉你也许你不该相信。我们到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，你有权保持愤怒。
This story is about a man whose job was to uphold the law and he was terrible at it. He says he's changed though, completely changed. Lilly Sullivan, one of our producers, heard about him from some video she saw.
这个故事是关于一个以执法为工作但却极其糟糕的人。但他声称自己改变了，彻底改变了。莉莉·沙利文，我们的一位制片人，从她看到的视频中听说了他。
There's this news story. I've watched it a bunch of times, my friend sent it to me. Not because she thought I'd like it-- she knew I wouldn't.
有这么个新闻故事。我看了很多次，我朋友发给我的。不是因为她觉得我会喜欢——她知道我不会。
It all went down on this block in Benton Harbor, Michigan. Jameel McGee says he was minding his own business when a police officer accused him of, and arrested him for, dealing drugs.
这一切发生在密歇根州本顿港的这个街区。贾米尔·麦基说他当时只是各干各的，一个警察指控他贩毒并将他逮捕。
Are you saying the officer made it up?
你是说那个警察编造的？
Yeah, it was all made up.
对，全是编造的。
This was on CBS national news in 2016. The guy talking, who got framed, is black. The cop who framed him is white. So after it comes out that the guy had been wrongly convicted he gets out of prison. He'd been in for three years. And he gets this job at a coffee shop. You know who his boss is? The cop, the guy who framed him. He was now the manager there.
这是2016年CBS全国新闻。那个被诬陷、正在谈论的人是黑人。那个诬陷他的警察是白人。所以在那个男人被错误定罪的事实浮出水面后，他出狱了。他在里面待了三年。然后他在咖啡店得到了一份工作。你知道他的老板是谁吗？那个警察，诬陷他的那个人。他现在是那里的经理。
By sheer coincidence, they now work side by side in the same cafe.
纯属巧合，他们现在在那家咖啡馆并肩工作。
Excuse me?
抱歉？
And it was in these cramped quarters that the bad cop and the wrongfully accused had no choice but to have it out.
正是在这种狭窄的空间里，坏警察和被诬陷者别无选择，只能摊牌。
The cop apologized, and the guy who was framed forgave him.
警察道歉了，被诬陷的那个人原谅了他。
That was pretty much what I needed to hear.
那差不多是我需要听到的全部了。
Today, they're not only cordial, they're friends.
今天，他们不仅友好，而且是朋友。
The reporter couldn't stop fawning over how lovely it was.
记者滔滔不绝地吹捧这是多么美好。
Such close friends, not long ago, Jameel actually told Andrew he loved him.
如此亲密的朋友，不久前，贾米尔甚至告诉安德鲁他爱他。
The problem with this story was, it wasn't the whole story. When my friend sent it to me, she told me the cop, whose name is Andrew Collins, he didn't just put one innocent guy in prison. I Googled this cop and it turns out he falsified police reports and warrants. He lied on the stand. At least 62 cases were either overturned or got thrown out.
这个故事的问题在于，它不是全部的故事。我朋友发给我时，她告诉我那个叫安德鲁·柯林斯的警察，他不仅仅把一个无辜者关进监狱。我用谷歌搜索了这个警察，结果发现他伪造警方报告和搜查令。他在证人席上撒谎。至少62起案件被推翻或撤销。
The small town of Benton Harbor ended up having to pay five and a half million dollars in settlements for civil rights violations. Then he befriends one guy and all that goes away? None of the other 61 victims even gets a mention? And then he gets to go on TV and tell his story over and over, because annoyingly, America seems to love this kind of story of forgiveness.
本顿港这个小镇最终不得不支付550万美元的和解金，因为侵犯民权。然后他与一个人成为朋友，这一切就消失了？其他61名受害者甚至连名字都没提？然后他能去电视上不断地讲述他的故事，因为令人恼火的是，美国似乎热衷于这种宽恕的故事。
This involves my next guest, Jameel, and former police officer, Andrew.
这涉及到我的下一位嘉宾贾米尔，以及前警察安德鲁。
That's talk show host, Steve Harvey. And here's Megyn Kelly on NBC.
那是脱口秀主持人史蒂夫·哈维。还有NBC的梅根·凯利。
Now our series, "Hopeful Holidays," and the story of two men who prove there is always hope for forgiveness and redemption.
现在是我们的系列报道“希望假期”，两个证明宽恕和救赎永远有希望的男人的故事。
Mike Huckabee on Fox.
福克斯的迈克·赫卡比。
I don't know of anything more powerful to help us through not only forgiveness and grace, but also racial reconciliation. And God bless you both.
除了宽恕和恩典，以及种族和解，我不认为有什么比这更有力量能帮助我们了。愿上帝保佑你们两个。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Racial reconciliation-- really? That's pretty big, as if this one story could hit Undo on a whole country's worth of harm. These stories are always about people who forgive, preaching this forgiveness thing as some kind of tidy remedy that can set the world right.
种族和解——真的吗？那可真是了不起，就好像这一个故事就能撤销一个国家所带来的所有伤害一样。这些故事总是关于那些宽恕他人的人，鼓吹宽恕是一种可以矫正世界的灵丹妙药。
And clearly, if these two guys in the coffee shop can set aside their bitter grounds, what's our excuse?
显然，如果咖啡馆里的这两个人都能放下恩怨，我们的借口是什么？
Look, I'm not from this town. This had nothing to do with me. But I wondered if lots of people there saw this coverage and rolled their eyes. What about the people who don't forgive? Visit Benton Harbor. They're not hard to find.
听着，我不是这个镇的人。这与我无关。但我好奇那里是否很多人看了这些报道并翻了白眼。那些不宽恕的人呢？去本顿港看看。他们并不难找。
Fuck him. Fuck him. I'm serious. I'm good.
去他的。去他的。我是认真的。我很好。
This is Robert Walker, also known as White Boy Rob.
这是罗伯特·沃克，也叫“白人罗伯”。
Why do they call you White Boy Rob?
为什么叫你“白人罗伯”？
Because my mom's white.
因为我妈是白人。
You don't look white.
你看上去不像白人。
Why, thank you.
谢谢。
I met him at his house. Or the truth is, I surprised him at his house. I found him in his backyard, riding his lawnmower in his sweatpants. Rob's definitely noticed that no one's doing a TV story about how he feels about this cop.
我是在他家见的他。或者是事实是，我在他家突然出现。我发现他在后院，穿着运动裤骑着割草机。罗伯肯定注意到了没人在做关于他对这个警察感觉如何的电视报道。
When they went to the Steve Harvey show, why you ain't take me? You ain't take me because I was going to tell you the motherfucking truth. You-- you hyping up this big thing about one person forgiving you. That ain't the only person that you fucked over.
当他们去史蒂夫·哈维秀的时候，为什么你不带我？你没带我是因为我要告诉你他妈的真相。你——你炒作这一件关于一个人宽恕你的大事。那不是你他妈毁掉的唯一一个人。
That's not-- and it pisses me off that, you know, y'all kissing buddy buddies, but what about everybody else that you done in? What about everybody else?
这不——这让我很生气，你知道，你们在那亲热，但其他人呢？你对其他被你坑的人做了什么？其他人呢？
Rob says Collins was so corrupt that people would do all kinds of things just to stay out of his way. For a while, one of the local radio stations, 105.3, would warn people whenever Collins was on duty. This one time, they did a special show-- call in and tell us your Corrupt Collins story. So one day, Rob's at a stoplight and he sees Collins in the lane next to him.
罗伯说柯林斯腐败到人们会做各种事情来避开他。有一阵子，当地电台105.3只要柯林斯执勤就会警告大家。有一次，他们做了一个特别节目——打进来告诉我们你关于腐败柯林斯的故事。有一天，罗伯在红绿灯处看到柯林斯在旁边的车道。
I was on M139 in Pipestone. I was in a black Impala SS. This is actually like a race car. He was next to me in a Ford Taurus, which is a putt-putt to me. Then when I was at the stop light, I looked over at him. He looked over at me. And then when I turned, he just jumped straight behind me. At this point, I'm thinking that he's going to plant some drugs on me.
我在Pipestone的M139公路上。我开着一辆黑色Impala SS。这其实像辆赛车。他在我旁边开着一辆福特金牛座，对我来说就是辆破车。然后在红绿灯处，我看向他。他看向我。然后当我转弯时，他直接跳到我后面。这时候，我在想他要往我车里塞毒品了。
Collins throws on his lights and sirens. And Rob's like, I'm not stopping. Instead, he says, he just keeps driving, under the speed limit with Collins following him, lights and sirens on. Rob drives for four minutes like this, all the way to the police station, the only place he thinks he might be safe.
柯林斯打开灯和警笛。罗伯心想，我不停。相反，他说，他只是继续开车，保持在限速以下，柯林斯跟在他后面，灯光和警笛齐鸣。罗伯就这样开了四分钟，一直开到警察局，他认为那里是唯一安全的地方。
I went to the police station and told them, he want to search my car. Could you please watch him so he won't plant nothing in my car?
我去了警察局告诉他们，他想搜查我的车。能不能请你们盯着他，好让他不会在我车里塞任何东西？
What did they say to you?
他们跟你说了什么？
Nothing. They watched. They watched him search. They knew. They knew he was dirty.
什么都没说。他们看着。他们看着他搜查。他们知道。他们知道他是脏的。
I mean, come on, what guy is going to pull up to the police station, get arrested, and the whole time, I'm not worried about nothing? I'm just worried about him planting something. Y'all watch him and make sure he don't plant nothing.
我的意思是，得了吧，什么人会开到警察局被逮捕，整个过程中我一点都不担心？我只担心他塞东西。你们看着他，确保他没塞任何东西。
Rob went to jail that day. Not for drugs-- Collins didn't find any. But he arrested Rob anyway for fleeing and eluding. Rob didn't do much time, a couple of days, bonded out $3,000. But he did get convicted. In Michigan, fleeing and eluding is a felony. It's still on his record.
罗伯那天进了监狱。不是因为毒品——柯林斯没搜到任何东西。但柯林斯还是以“逃避和躲避”罪名逮捕了罗伯。罗伯没坐几年牢，几天而已，交了3000美元保释金。但他确实被定罪了。在密歇根州，逃避追捕是重罪。这还在他的记录上。
This other guy, Quacy Roberts, suffered more. In 2008, Quacy was leaving his girlfriend's house, hot summer day, when Collins and his partner pulled up. The partner said he'd seen Quacy throw something. Collins patted Quacy down while his partner walked around the block.
另一个人，奎西·罗伯茨，受的苦更多。2008年，奎西离开女友家，大热天，柯林斯和搭档开了过来。搭档说看到奎西扔了什么东西。柯林斯搜身奎西，而他的搭档绕着街区走了一圈。
The partner came back and waved a baggie of crack in Quacy's face. Quacy says it wasn't his, but he ended up serving a year in jail. It was a terrible year to be in jail. He and his girlfriend were about to have a baby. The baby didn't make it.
搭档回来时把一小袋可卡因挥在奎西脸上。奎西说那不是他的，但他最终坐了一年牢。那是极度糟糕的一年。他和女友刚要有一个孩子。那个孩子没保住。
When you have a stillborn, it's really a person. You got to go through all those stages, name it, get a social security number and everything. You got to go through everything. It's a person. You got to bury it.
当你有一个死产儿时，他真是一个人。你得经历所有那些阶段，命名他，获得社会保障号码等等。你得经历一切。他是一个人。你得安葬他。
He still thinks about the baby.
他还在想那个孩子。
Yes, because he was mine.
是的，因为他是我的。
Quacy couldn't be with his girlfriend for any of that. He had to hear about it through the prison phone. Not long after that, his girlfriend met someone else. So he's pretty angry at Collins.
奎西没能陪在女友身边经历那些。他不得不通过监狱电话听到这个消息。不久后，他女友遇见了别人。所以他对柯林斯很生气。
Quacy's seen those news stories too. His mom called him once and told him to turn on the Megyn Kelly show, one of those stories with Andrew Collins and Jameel McGee, the guy who forgave him.
奎西也看到了那些新闻报道。他妈有次打给他，让他打开梅根·凯利秀，那个关于安德鲁·柯林斯和贾米尔·麦基（那个原谅他的男人）的故事。
It's good that McGee smiling about everything. He must didn't lose nobody. He blessed. I guess he blessed.
麦基对一切都在微笑很好。他一定没失去任何人。他有福气。我想他有福气。
He's blessed?
他有福气？
Yeah, I guess he did four years and didn't lose nobody. I did a year and lost a son. So I'm-- I think an Andrew Collins interview with me would be-- I won't be showing no teeth for grinning at him. Maybe if I wouldn't have lost my child, maybe I'd be smiling too.
是啊，我猜他坐了四年牢没失去任何人。我坐了一年失去了儿子。所以我——我想安德鲁·柯林斯采访我不会是——我不会对着他露牙齿笑的。也许如果我没失去孩子，我也能笑。
Quacy hasn't seen Collins since he went to jail, so Quacy never got an apology. But he thinks he deserves one. I asked if he wanted to meet with Collins. He said yeah.
奎西进监狱后就没见过柯林斯，所以从未收到道歉。但他认为他应得一个。我问他想见柯林斯吗。他说想。
It was easier to find Collins. He actually has a publicist from when he and Jameel wrote a book together. It came out last year. It's described as "an unlikely journey of forgiveness and friendship." Collins is big-- 6'1", blue eyes, dresses like a surfer who's also on the football team, who's also in a Christian punk band-- flip-flops, shorts, a few tattoos, some with scripture.
找柯林斯更容易。他和贾米尔合写一本书后有了一名公关。那本书去年出版。被描述为“一段关于宽恕和友谊的不太可能的旅程”。柯林斯很强壮——6英尺1英寸，蓝眼睛，穿得像个同时是足球队队员、同时在基督朋克乐队里的冲浪运动员——人字拖，短裤，一些纹身，有些带有经文。
These days, he freely admits that he'd pull people over without probable cause, write phony police reports, falsify warrants, plant drugs in people's cars. I think one of the ways he's able to sleep at night is that he believes nearly all the people he wrongly arrested were drug dealers. He thought they should be in jail. And about those TV stories, I was surprised, but Collins actually agrees with me. He thinks it's messed up how they all focus on him and Jameel and forgiveness and ignore the harm he did to so many people in the community.
这些天，他自由承认他会无端拦下人们，写虚假的警察报告，伪造搜查令，在人们车里塞毒品。我想他能入睡的原因之一是他认为所有被他错误逮捕的人都是毒贩。他认为他们就该进监狱。关于那些电视故事，我很惊讶，但柯林斯其实同意我的看法。他认为那些报道把重点全部集中在他和贾米尔以及宽恕上，而忽略了他在社区里造成的伤害，这太搞砸了。
It's not a story about a community, though. It should be, but it hasn't been. It's been told as a story about Jameel and I, just this fun-loving story, this fun, cute story we can pet. But I don't-- I've never met a reporter that's like, I would like to meet somebody who still hates you.
不过，这并不是关于一个社区的故事。它本应该是，但它不是。它被讲述成关于贾米尔和我的故事，只是这个充满乐趣的故事，这个我们能随意抚摸的有趣、可爱的故事。但我还没见过一个记者说：“我想见见一个仍然恨你的人。”
I'm happy to be that reporter. And he said he was game to meet with Quacy. He sees as his responsibility to apologize as much as he can. It's his restitution, he says. And he has a whole way he deals with conversations like this. He's worked out all the words, the best way to do it.
我很乐意做那个记者。他说他愿意和奎西见面。他视向尽可能多的人道歉为自己的责任。他说这是他的赔偿。他有一套处理这类谈话的方法。他已经想好了所有话，最好的表达方式。
It's all about owning what you did and giving people a chance to lament the wrong things you did. And then I'll say, you're exactly-- you're absolutely right. I'm so sorry for those things I did.
全是关于承认你做过的事，并给人们一个机会去哀悼你所做的错误的事情。然后我会说：“你是对的——你绝对是对的。我很抱歉我做的那些事。”
And it-- it kind of sucks the anger out of somebody when the offender is standing right in front of you saying, you're right. No, no justification, no minimizing, no-- no reason. I can't give you any reason why I did it. There's no good reason why I did that to you, and I owe you an apology.
当冒犯者就站在你面前说“你是对的”时，它会吸走一个人的愤怒。没理由，不最小化，不——没理由。我无法给你任何我这样做的理由。我那样对待你没有好理由，我欠你一个道歉。
Collins suggested that he and Quacy meet at the office of this Christian organization where he volunteers. It had been 10 years since they'd seen each other.
柯林斯建议他和奎西在他担任志愿者的基督教组织办公室见面。那是他们上次见面十年后了。
What's up, man?
怎么了，老兄？
What's going on with you?
你最近怎么样？
How you doing? Long time no see. You haven't aged a bit, man.
你最近怎么样？好久不见。你一点都没老，老兄。
No, I have haven't.
不，我没有。
What they say, black don't crack?
他们怎么说来着，黑人不会变老？
No, it crack. Especially if you drink a whole lot.
不，会变老。尤其是如果你喝太多酒的话。
Right. No, man, you look good. I'm not used to seeing you without a hat, though.
对。没，老兄，你看起来不错。不过我不习惯没戴帽子的你。
Oh, yeah. You is what you is.
哦，是的。你是什么样就是什么样。
There you go. There you go.
就是这样。就是这样。
You guys remember each other now?
你们现在还记得对方吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I remember like it was yesterday.
我记得就像昨天一样。
They sit down. Collins says, I'm trying to remember exactly how I know you. I know we've had plenty of run-ins.
他们坐下。柯林斯说，我试着准确记住我怎么认识你的。我知道我们有很多摩擦。
I don't want to say that, like, from the beginning. Like, so it's been 10 years since I've even been there. So if I don't remember specifics, like, that's not to disrespect you or anything like that, because I know this was very personal to you. It's just that I don't remember. There was so many people and I did so many bad things, so.
我不从头开始说。就像十年没去过那里一样。所以如果我没记住细节，那不是不尊重你，因为我知道这对你非常私人。只是我不记得了。有太多人了，我做了太多坏事，所以。
I'll start to make it specific, because I still have the police report.
我会开始说具体点，因为我还有警方报告。
They talk about the day that Collins and his partner arrested Quacy. Collins' partner was dirty, too. He went to prison after Collins did. And he's actually the one who said he saw Quacy throw the baggie of drugs, which Quacy says he didn't do. Collins says he remembers going back to the spot later to take photos for the trial and realizing his partner was probably lying. He couldn't have seen what he said he saw. There were trees in the way.
他们谈到了柯林斯和搭档逮捕奎西的那天。他的搭档也是个坏警察。他在柯林斯之后进了监狱。他其实才是那个说看到奎西扔毒品的人，奎西说他没干。柯林斯说他记得后来回到那个地点为审判拍照，意识到他的搭档可能撒谎了。他不可能看到他所说的情况。中间有树挡着。
So I remember thinking then, like, OK, my partner might have stretched the truth a little bit. But I still was convinced you were guilty because he said you were guilty, right? So--
所以我记得当时想，好吧，我的搭档可能夸大了事实。但我还是确信你是内疚的，因为他说你内疚，对吧？所以——
It's what the police say.
那是警察说的。
I know I wanted you, though. I know I wanted you to be guilty.
我知道我想要你，虽然。我知道我想要你有罪。
Why?
为什么？
Quacy bothered me when I was a police officer, because he didn't-- he didn't just shut up. Like, he'd tell me my breath stunk, and--
奎西当我做警察时惹恼了我，因为他不会——他不会闭嘴。比如，他会告诉我的呼吸很臭，然后——
I'd never--
我从来没——
Quacy thought Collins had gotten off way too easy for what he did. He only spent a year and a half in jail. Colin says he hears that a lot.
奎西认为柯林斯因为他做的事而过得太轻松了。他只在监狱里待了一年半。柯林斯说他经常听到这个。
I think there are some people that would say, day for day, whatever those other people did in jail, he should have to do that now-- day for day.
我想有些人会说，日复一日，不管那些人在监狱里做了什么，他现在也该做到——日复一日。
Right. That would have sounded good. That would have been fair. Like whatever, you can set it by saying, one person got two to five. Another person got 40-something months to something months. Take all them, add all of them together, and see can you face up to them? Bad mofo, ooh. Yeah, yeah, that'd be appropriate. Yeah.
对。那听起来不错。那会很公平。就像无论什么，你可以通过说“一个人得到了两到五年，另一个人得到了40多个月”来设定。把它们全加上，看看能不能面对它们？坏家伙，哦。是的，是的，那很恰当。
I'm glad it didn't happen. But I could see that argument.
很高兴那没发生。但我能理解那个论点。
Yeah.
是啊。
A lot of the conversation was awkward. Collins took a long time to get to his apology, and when he did, it was kind of indirect. It seems like Quacy barely even noticed.
大部分谈话很尴尬。柯林斯花了好长时间才说到道歉，即使说了，也比较间接。奎西似乎几乎没注意到。
Even though I wasn't the one that said I saw you throw it, it was my influence in that situation that brought my partner to a place where he felt comfortable saying those lies, if they were lies, right? So therefore, I do owe you an- I believe, man to man, I owe you an apology because I operated in the system that's broken. And I helped make it--
即使不是我说看到你扔的，也是我在那个情况下的影响把我的搭档带到了一个他觉得可以说谎（如果是谎言的话）的位置，对吧？所以我认为，男人对男人，我欠你一个道歉，因为我在一个破碎的系统中运作。我帮忙让它——
So what you--
所以你——
--even more broken.
——更破碎了。
So what you saying is, you could have just been more blunt like that.
所以你是说，你本可以更直截了当地那样说。
What got to Quacy more than the apology was something that they saw eye to eye on, and kind of bonded over. For most of the hour, they talked about how bad the policing is in Benton Harbor. Benton Harbor is 85% black with a police department that's mostly white that has a history of misconduct. There have been decades of protests against the police and a few riots.
比道歉更能打动奎西的是他们的共识，并因此有了共鸣。大部分时间，他们都在谈论本顿港的警察有多糟糕。本顿港85%是黑人，警察部门大部分是白人，有不当行为的历史。几十年来一直在抗议警察，发生过几次暴乱。
Collins has named names in court depositions, talked about how many officers were complicit in bad policing. He spends a lot of his book detailing illegal behavior by cops that he says he witnessed and participated in. He talks to police trainees about corruption and racism and how easy it is to slip into those things.
柯林斯在法庭证词中指名道姓，谈论了多少警官共谋了糟糕的警务。他花了很多书的篇幅详细叙述了他目睹并参与的警察非法行为。他告诉警察受训人员关于腐败和种族歧视，以及陷入这些事情有多容易。
So he and Quacy got into all of that. They know the same stories, same cops and judges and prosecutors, people they both believe to be crooked who never got caught. There's lots of insider talk.
所以他和奎西深入探讨了这一切。他们知道同样的故事，同样的警察、法官和检察官，他们都认为那些人是骗子，但从没被抓住。有很多内部交谈。
Right.
对。
You see Officer [BLEEP] on film. I'm telling them, I want to subpoena Officer [BLEEP]. Oh, we can't find him. We don't know where he at.
你看到警官[哔]在电影上。我告诉他们，我想传唤警官[哔]。哦，我们找不到他。我们不知道他在哪。
Yeah. He still works there, don't he?
对。他还在那工作，不是吗？
Right.
对。
That's crazy, man. Different officer, same candy wrapper. But the system itself is-- man, it's just full of corruption. You know, you see corruption day in and day out. You stop viewing people as human. You start to see them as, you know, the next prize, the next notch in my belt, in my career, right?
那太疯狂了，老兄。不同的警察，同样的糖纸。但系统本身——男人，它充满了腐败。你知道，你日复一日地看到腐败。你不再把人看作人类。你开始把他们看作，你知道，下一个奖品，我在我职业生涯中的下一个记录，对吧？
Collins really was trying to connect and win Quacy over. He even offered to help Quacy with a case he has pending.
柯林斯确实在试图联系并赢得奎西。他甚至提出帮奎西处理他手头的一个案子。
You want me to take a copy of the report? Well, I mean, if you want to, give me the report. Let me look through it. Trust. I'm not a lawyer, but I've seen crooked police work before. Let me look through it and just show you like, hey, fight this, fight this, fight this.
你想让我拿一份报告复印件吗？好吧，我的意思是，如果你想的话，给我报告。让我看看。信任。我不是律师，但我之前见过卑鄙的警察工作。让我看看它，给你指出，嘿，反击这个，反击这个，反击这个。
They seem to get along fine. They were polite enough. Quacy seemed like, whatever. An ex-cop who says he's on your side? It can't hurt.
他们似乎相处得很好。他们足够客气。奎西似乎觉得，无所谓了。一个说站在你这一边的前警察？没坏处。
After it was over, I walked with Quacy to his car.
结束后，我和奎西一起走到他的车前。
So how are you feeling?
所以你感觉如何？
I'm feeling all right.
我觉得还可以。
You're not mad at him?
你不生他的气？
How can you get mad to a person that we ain't even at the bottom of the situation yet?
你怎能对一个我们还没到情况底层的人感到生气？
Meaning, Collins didn't invent dirty policing, but he admitted to it. Collins confirmed everything Quacy already believed about the courts and prosecutors and judges, and about the Benton Harbor police who usually deny everything.
意思是，柯林斯没发明卑鄙的警务，但他承认了。柯林斯证实了奎西已经相信的关于法院、检察官和法官，以及通常否认一切的本顿港警察的一切。
But by us talking, we find out, 10 years later, that he on the same page that I'm on, fighting against the same people that I'm fighting against. He looking at the police point of view in the system. I'm looking at the street point of view of the system. So both of us looking at it both ways, his way and my way. And I'm looking at it my way and his way.
但通过谈话，我们发现，10年后，他和我在同一页面上，反抗着我反抗着的同样的人。他看着系统中警察的观点。我看着系统中街道的观点。所以我们俩都以两种方式看着它，他的方式和我的方式。我以我的方式和他的方式看着它。
Rob Walker, who used to be known as White Boy Rob, he sees things differently.
罗伯特·沃克，曾经被称为“白人罗伯”，他看待事物的方式不同。
At this point in my life, if he did apologize, it don't mean shit. Honestly? I just want one chance to whoop his ass.
在我人生的这个阶段，如果他道歉了，那也一点意义没有。老实说？我只想要一次机会揍他一顿。
As I said, he didn't want to talk with Collins. But he told me they did bump into each other accidentally. It's a small town. It happened at that cafe from the news story.
如我所说，他不想和柯林斯谈。但他告诉我他们偶然撞见了对方。那是个小镇。这发生在新闻报道里的那家咖啡馆。
So when I see him, I said-- I said, Collins. And he looked. And when he looked at me, I said, man, you've been on some bullshit. He want to talk about how that ain't him no more. Well, I told him, I don't want any of that shit.
所以当我看到他时，我说——我说，柯林斯。他看了看。当他看着我时，我说，老兄，你一直在搞些狗屁。他想谈谈那不再是他了。嗯，我告诉他，我不想听那些狗屁。
That don't help me. It don't help me that you want to-- all of the sudden you want to change. Oh, let me ask you-- I'm going to be totally honest with you. Did he understand that I changed?
那对我没帮助。你想要——突然你想要改变，那对我没帮助。哦，让我问你——我要对你非常诚实。他理解我改变了吗？
He'd changed a lot. Back when Collins arrested him, he'd been away from drugs for years. Everyone knew that, he says. He even put on his license plate, game over. And it was on his car that day that Collins pulled him over.
他改变了很多。柯林斯逮捕他时，他已经远离毒品好几年了。每个人都知道，他说。他甚至在车牌上写了“游戏结束”。那天柯林斯拦下他时，那就在他车上。
Rob's gotten plaques from the city for his community work. He started an annual picnic with free rides and food, paid for it all out of pocket. But he still has a felony on his record from that run-in with Collins.
罗伯因社区工作获得了城市的奖牌。他开始了一年一度的野餐，免费乘车和食物，全是自己掏钱。但他因那次与柯林斯的冲突在记录上还有一个重罪。
So why should I understand he changed? I shouldn't. I should get to treat you the same way you treat me. You never understood that I changed, that that wasn't my life no more. Now that you claiming that you changed, I feel the same way.
所以为什么我应该理解他改变了？我不应该。我应该能像你对待我一样对待你。你从没理解我改变了，那不再是我的生活了。现在你声称你改变了，我感觉一样。
You still a dirty motherfucker to me. I don't care what did you say. If Collins had a chance to do it all over again, he'd do it all over again. Dirty cop-- he was a dirty cop, he is. And to me, that forgiveness shit is overrated.
对我来说你还是个卑鄙的混蛋。我不管你说了什么。如果柯林斯有机会重来一遍，他还是会重来一遍。卑鄙警察——他是个卑鄙警察，他是。对我来说，那个宽恕的狗屁被高估了。
A takeaway which, of course, is the opposite of all of those news stories.
这是一个收获，当然，与所有那些新闻故事相反。
Is there a lesson for America from this?
这对美国有什么教训吗？
No.
没有。
The story of someone who doesn't forgive, who thinks being angry is a totally reasonable way to feel. Yeah, maybe it's not heartwarming. But what's wrong with bearing a grudge forever? It could be something to hold onto that keeps you sane.
一个不宽恕的人的故事，一个认为愤怒是一个完全合理的感受方式的人的故事。是的，也许它不暖心。但永远怀恨在心有什么错？它可能是可以坚持的东西，让你保持理智。
Lilly Sullivan is one of the producers of our show.
莉莉·沙利文是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "MAKE A CHANGE" BY DURAND JONES & THE INDICATIONS]
[音乐 - “MAKE A CHANGE” BY DURAND JONES & THE INDICATIONS]
(SINGING) To make you want me I can fabricate the truth. I'll give you easy, it'll keep me destitute. You hang me up on the line, hang me out to dry, and you got nothing to lose.
（歌唱）为了让你想要我，我可以编造真相。我给你容易的，它会让我赤贫。你把我挂在线上，把我挂出来晾干，你没什么可失去的。
Our program is produced today by Robyn Semien. The people who put together our show today include Ellen Baker, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Jarrett Floyd, Damien Grave, David Kestenbaum, Nikki Meek, Alvin Mellot, Nadia Raymond, Alyssa Ship, Julie Snyder, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton. Special thanks to Carolina Iwanow, Louise Seamster, Paz Saravia, Laura Rajchman, Barbara Barisch, Naomi Daremblum, Joanna Broder, Reverend Edward Pinkney, Gregory Warner, Ashley Lopez, and Ben Philpott.
我们今天的节目由罗宾·塞米恩制作。今天制作我们节目的人包括艾伦·贝克、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、惠特尼·丹杰菲尔德、尼尔·德鲁明、贾雷特·弗洛伊德、达米安·格雷夫、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、尼基·米克、阿尔文·梅洛特、纳迪亚·雷蒙德、艾丽莎·希普、朱莉·斯奈德、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼。我们的高级制作人是布莱恩·里德。我们的执行主编是苏珊·伯顿。特别感谢卡罗琳娜·伊万诺、路易丝·西姆斯、帕兹·萨拉维亚、劳拉·拉杰奇曼、芭芭拉·巴里施、内奥米·达伦布鲁姆、乔安娜·布罗德、爱德华·平克尼牧师、格雷戈里·华纳、阿什利·洛佩兹和本·菲尔波特。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he was complaining today about how he'd gotten two tickets-- two, both for littering.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过600集的档案。 《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）分发到公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他今天还在抱怨他收到了两张罚单——两张，都是因为乱扔垃圾。
Different officer, same candy wrapper.
不同的警察，同样的糖纸。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "MAKE A CHANGE" BY DURAND JONES & THE INDICATIONS]
[音乐 - “MAKE A CHANGE” BY DURAND JONES & THE INDICATIONS]